usually people are really confused when
I tell them what I do I tell them like
yeah you want to fingerboard company
like those tech tax used to get in
someone's like yeah but professional
skateboarding makes me feel awesome it
doesn't get boring it's always a
challenge there's no rules finger
boarding and skateboarding both have
that
I started fingerboarding in 4th grade I
had a lot of fun playing with the tech
decks and then I wanted to kind of
improve them a lot of times the screws
would come out so I'd glue them in and
just start modifying things like that
and I just realized I could make them
better and better a lot of kids wanted
to buy them so I kind of put a name on
it and it grew into this huge business
over time there's hundreds of thousands
of people out there that are into this
we are at the flat-faced rendezvous
location in Dracut Massachusetts and
it's pretty much a big building filled
with fingerboard parks and I do huge
events here where kids fly in from all
over the place to come and fingerboard
together when you go into a contest
that's crazy because there's stadium
seating and there's everyone looking at
you and lighting and cameras my first
few contests I got crazy adrenaline rush
like you don't even remember the thing
after you do your run I don't do any
warm-ups or exercises with my hands for
fingerboarding apparently some people do
calisthenics the rules are pretty much
you want to use two fingers you'll have
maybe thirty seconds or a minute or so
and you just do a run and there will be
a whole bunch of judges will judge you
on consistency style the tricks you do
it's like really high pressure
you can't even really put it into words
it's a crazy kind of feeling and
atmosphere when so many people get
together from all over the world all
over the country and some of them it's
like a really really big deal to them
like that's the only thing they want to
do all year it just makes me super happy
because I can barely believe that I'm
the reason they're there like because of
something that I set up and that I'm
doing
you